buenos días ha iniciado este encuentro
entre los dos líderes que ha empezado
pocos minutos antes de los dos líderes
con sus esposas disfrutando esta bella
vista que ustedes pueden ver a mis
espaldas de la costa inglesa disfrutando
de el buen clima podría decirse
disfrutando de la vista de una de las
zonas más bellas de inglaterra pero que
es al mismo tiempo una de las más
deprimidas y de las más pobres ha sido
un encuentro muy esperado la primera
bilateral entre dos de los hombres más
poderosos del mundo de lo que se espera
salga un compromiso real de cómo estos
países desarrollados van a ayudar a que
los países más pobres que están en vías
de desarrollo puedan tener acceso rápido
a las vacunas les cuento que ha llamado
la atención mucho la chaqueta de la
primera dama de los eeuu gilbert que
tiene un mensaje amor preguntado por la
prensa de los eeuu la señora bailén dijo
que eso es lo que espera traer a la
cumbre una cumbre mundial de la dos
naciones más poderosas del mundo y es
dar ese mensaje de unidad
podemos esperar también de esta reunión
bilateral que eeuu y el reino unido
anuncie lo que será el capítulo
atlántico que defenderá los valores de
la democracia acciones concretas contra
el cambio climático y también como les
digo cómo luchar contra la pandemia del
hobbit pero también será la oportunidad
para que se empiece a preparar entonces
la antesala de la cumbre del g7 que
arranca mañana aquí en el jornal hacia
el vice con respecto a la pandemia que
más podemos esperar de esta reunión
compromisos concretos espera que domine
gran parte de las sesiones de la cumbre
qué hacer con la pandemia como los
países desarrollados pueden ayudar a la
recuperación de la economía en todo el
mundo pero lo que más compete en este
momento es justamente cómo ayudar a que
toda la población internacional pueda
ser vacunada rápidamente que es un poco
contradictorio porque las naciones del
g7 especialmente eeuu y el reino unido-
avanzan rápidamente en esta campaña de
vacunación pero no los otros países
sobre todos los países en vías de
desarrollo así que lo concreto lo que se
espera que salga de aquí es el plan de
cómo se estos países van a ayudar a que
esos países accedan a las vacunas y por
supuesto cuántas vacunas van a donar
para el país el mundo en desarrollo
luisa gracias por toda la información
buen día